mississippi led the challenge that
finally overturned roe v wade that
state's law limiting abortion was
declared unconstitutional by lower
courts until the supreme court ruled on
friday kaitlin huey burns is in jackson
mississippi outside the state's only
abortion clinic where there's concern
that women will lose access to a wide
range of essential services caitlin good
morning
good morning vlad well this clinic
behind me is known here as the pink
house but it's also known as being the
center of that landmark ruling and over
the weekend they actually expanded hours
to try and see as many patients as they
could before the attorney general here
makes them close their doors
dorinda hancock and her volunteer group
the pink defenders spent the weekend as
they have for years escorting women past
protesters and into mississippi's only
abortion clinic they can block this road
because they know those are patients who
need access to get right in that
driveway she says the defenders will be
there until the clinic closes its doors
for good all we've been through here
will always be a part of our lives
the patience that we've seen
and
that we've been able to give a little
comfort to
but elsewhere the decision is seen as an
answered prayer it was at the center of
sunday's service at broadmoor baptist
church where the pastor encouraged
adoption roe versus wade was overturned
and i pray yes we
we thank god for that
is the state prepared no for the
consequences no no it's not prepared
getty israel founded sisters in birth a
non-profit community health organization
serving pregnant women in jackson
mississippi is one of the top four
states with the highest
highest rate of young women who are
uninsured the same young women who don't
have access to reproductive care
namely contraception and now she's
pregnant and she's going to present with
risk factors like obesity
pre-hypertension pre-diabetes she's more
likely to raise that baby in poverty in
the mississippi delta one of the poorest
places in the nation some counties are
without a single obstetrician or
pediatrician already expected mothers
either don't have access to medical
professionals or must drive hours the
thing that's going to keep me up at
night
is the women who will lose their lives
because they don't have access to care
juaquina clanton the director of the
southern poverty law center in jackson
sees this as a call to action we will
not back down the people here
particularly the women here in
mississippi are primed for this moment
but in a state with the highest rate of
infant mortality of low birth weight and
of young child poverty israel says the
federal and local governments need to
step up and what does it mean for
these children
well i see it as a ditch put the mother
in the ditch put a child in the ditch
with her with her now add another one
and cover it with dirt
that's what we're dealing with
now tony most of the states around
mississippi are actually also banning
abortions so women seeking the procedure
will have to either fly long distances
or drive long distances and also at
question here is whether there will be
additional restrictions on ordering
abortion pills by mail tony
caitlin huey burns outside the clinic
where it all started caitlin thank you
very much